-Wow! Everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How does it feel? Tell me.
-We made it through the rain.
We're back! We're back!
-Yes!
Alright. And guess what?
I was about to come out.
I just found these sunglasses.
I've been looking for them
for over a year,
which was the last time
I wore this freaking suit.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-No joke.
-How ridiculous. Oh, my.
How are you feeling right now?
What did that just feel like?
-I feel great.
First of all...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...I understand
that this is only 58 people.
It is still more than double
the size of my normal audience.
-Yeah.
-This is certainly
the most people
I've seen in over a year.
-Yeah.
-This is great.
Your energy is awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's so cool
to be back at 30 Rock.
Great to see you.
-I got to talk to you
about the Clubhouse.
I want to talk about
the docuseries.
I want to talk about this.
-Yes.
-I'm so into this,
I can't even tell you.
You know me. I love reality TV.
-Thank you. I know you do.
-Can you believe this?
I'm doing research on you.
You've been on TV for
almost a decade? Over a decade.
-I've been on
over a decade, yeah.
About 15 years, I think.
"Watch What Happens: Live"
has been on 12 years.
-That's -- 12 years?
-Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
-You're amazing.
-You've been on 12 years --
You've been hosting "Late Night"
for 12 years.
-Yeah.
-On NBC.
-Yeah, you're right.
Kind of started together.
-Yeah.
-That's wild.
-I love you, and I --
Dude, the shows are
still phenomenal.
Even though you're doing it
during this pandemic,
the quarantine,
you're doing it all great.
And baby steps.
-Yeah. I can't wait
until we get an audience.
I mean, I'm just waiting.
-Oh, wait till you --
Wait till you get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But this --
I want to talk about this,
'cause this Thursday,
you have a new limited series
about the history
and impact of reality TV.
It's on E!
Set your DVRs,
9:00, this Thursday.
You know I'm the biggest fan.
So talk to me. What was --
-We go inside "The Bachelor,"
"The Kardashians,"
the "Housewives," "The Swan" --
Remember "The Swan"?
-Oh, my God.
-I interview a few contestants
from "The Swan"
and see how it all held up.
-Wait, wait. "The Swan,"
if I can remember well,
Was it someone
who did plastic surgery?
-It's kind of a plastic surgery
beauty pageant.
-Oh.
-You know, lot of great
ideas in reality TV.
Lot of maybe not-so-great ideas.
-Do you remember when I loved,
and it was everyone --
Obviously, you can't do it,
and you shouldn't have done it.
-Right. What?
-"Kid Nation,"
do you remember that?
we cover, absolutely.
A horrible idea.
Kids! It was basically
a reality "Lord of the Flies."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Like, who let their kids
go do that show?
-Dude, they ran the town.
-Oh, we definitely
talk about "Kid Nation."
We talk to some of
the former kids from the show.
-No!
-Yes, we do.
-No.
-We do. And we talk
to Molly and Jason
who fell in love
on "The Bachelor,"
and they really
sang like canaries
about producer involvement
and enhancement on that show.
I found it very interesting
and surprising.
-Really?
-Yes.
-And this other thing
that you talk about,
that I want to talk about
tonight, because this was odd.
I was talking to you backstage.
I said, you talked
to Khloé Kardashian,
and you said,
"I'm pronouncing her name --
We've all been pronouncing her
name wrong this whole time."
-It's "Klo-ay."
Khloé is the name.
There is a little accent
over the name.
And so, I went and interviewed
the Kardashians
at Khloé's house.
-Wait, wait. I'm so sorry.
No, no. I'm sorry.
-Yes.
-No, no, no, no.
-Sorry, sorry, but --
-Yeah, I'm sorry, too, but --
-Call her. Call her.
-I will call her Khloé.
-I walked in, I go, "Khloé"
and the other women go,
"Excuse me?"
And Chris said, "Yeah,
that's actually really
how it's pronounced."
-'Cause there is a little --
-There is a little thing
on top of the name.
Why am I the only one
that got that?
-Khloé?
-I got the memo.
-Khloé.
-Yes.
-Wow.
-Ask her.
-Wow! Khloé.
-Yes.
-It was wild. It was a trip
going to the Kardashians' house.
You got to go through
all these gates.
I had to get a COVID test
before I got there.
-Wait, like "Get Smart"?
-Kind of like "Get Smart."
And they were like, I said,
"Oh, you want to give me
the results of the COVID test?"
They go, "Go to Khloé's,
and if the second gate opens,
you're negative."
-Go to Khlo-B's.
Go to Khlo-B's.
-Yes. Go Khlo-B's.
And the gate opened. I was like,
"Alright, I don't have COVID.
I'm good."
-So you made it
through the second gate.
-I did, straight to the --
-And there's a third gate?
-There are so many gates,
I don't even remember, honestly.
-And what were they like?
-They were amazing.
The lighting setup
is very intense.
They looked so beautiful.
-They do.
-And they're all kind of
casually hanging out
on these swings
behind Khloé's house.
It was wild.
-I want to show everyone a clip
from the series.
Here's Andy Cohen
with the Kardashians
in "For Real:
The Story of Reality TV."
Take a look at this.
-What do you think
the legacy of the show is?
-Just family over everything.
I think at the start
of this show,
our first meeting was that
we just wanted to make sure
that our heart came through
and we didn't really leave
every episode with drama,
that it was back to the family,
back at heart.
-Well said. It's just
how we live our lives.
-Right.
-And we spend so much time
together off-camera.
Like, two nights ago,
we all ended up randomly
at Kim's house.
She had this chiropractor over,
and I was fixing something
and somebody else would walk in
and, you know.
-Rob was there.
-We had like three appointments
going on, like, in a circle.
Like, "Who wants a spray tan,
then the chiropractor,
then a facial?"
-Okay, that's the scenario
that I envision happening.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah,
that's exactly what --
-Who wants a spray tan?
-I cannot wait for this.
How many parts is this?
-Seven.
-Seven parts.
We cover every show.
-"Real World," MTV?
-Yes. I cried.
I reunited the original cast.
I cried when they came out.
I died.
-Wait, Eric?
-Eric.
-Heather B?
-Yeah, my girl Heather B, yes.
-Wow, I can't wait for this.
Andy and I are going
to go head-to-head
in "One-Second Reality TV Quiz"
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.